تخليني بس اقول رقم ونقول للناس كلها صباح
الخير اذا تم العقد وهو غالبا تم وتم
توقيع ميسي سيحصل على مليون يورو صباح كل
يوم
صباح العربيه
اكيد
350 مليون
350 مليون سنويا محمد هذا التصريح خطير
بالتوقع
ما اقدرش اؤكده مره ثانيه
وارجنتينيه الرقم قد ايه
600 سنتين يعني احنا مش عايزين نبان بس ان
احنا بنقع
هو بالتنجيل يستاهل ميسي
والهدف لميسي يستاهل دفع المال بالتاكيد
بنحكي عن 350 في السيزون
وبالتالي 600 في الموسمين لو حسبناه بحسبه
بسيطه تقريبا مليون كل يوم مليون
انت اكيد
عادل على كل حال شكرا جزيلا
الحديث لا ينتهي طبعا الصحفي الرياضي محمد
حامد كان معنا في الاستوديو شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات